et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Stanislas guini bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par Fabrice von du groupera
les journaux régionaux de l'Est de la
France bonjourrice bonjour bonjour
Stanislas gu on va évidemment parler de
la loi immigration jourg pour la
commission mixte paritaire vous êtes
plutôt un tenant de l'aile gauche vous
de la majorité est-ce que vous redoutez
un texte trop à droite moi je crois que
personne ne comprendra qu'il n'y ait pas
de
texte la semaine dernière le débat n'a
pas pu se faire c'est quasiment inédit
c'est regrettable c'est in
comompréhensible maintenant je crois que
les Français attendent qu'il a un texte
il y a des attendus qui sont extrêmement
fort sur l'immigration et donc nous
devons aboutir il y a un travail de fond
qui est mené pour essayer de trouver des
positions de compromis c'est ça la
politique j'aurais préféré qu'elle se
fasse à travers un débat parlementaire à
ciel ouvert mais la priorité c'est que
nous puissions avoir un texte sur les
frç comprendrait pas on se passe de
mesures qui permettent d'expulser des
délinquants qui permettent de raccourcir
des délais qui permettent au fond
d'apporter des solu
au problème que les Français constatent
mais les discussions se font en majorité
avec les
républicains c'est pour ça que je vous
demande est-ce que vous ne craigz pas un
texte trop àite vous dites il vaut mieux
un texte à droite plutôt que pas de
texte c'est la position qui résulte des
débats nous repartons du texte de la
majorité sénatoriale c'est la démocratie
parlementaire que ça et donc il faut le
respecter faut essayer de trouver les
bonnes positions sur chacun des sujets
il y a un énorme travail qui est mené un
énorme travail par ministre de
l'intérieur par la première ministre
elle-même en première ligne pour trouver
dans notre vie parlementaire les
compromis nécessairire pour que nous
puissions avoir un texte efficace sur
l'immigration il y a un certain nombre
de sujets qui étaient sur la table qui
était des sujets les plus difficiles
celui de laame celui de l'accès aux
aides sociales celui du droit du sol
celui de l'hébergement d'urgence sur
tous ces sujets-là vous l'avez entendu
avant moi été présent Philippe car qui
est un des sénateurs qui sera présent
dans cette commission mixte paritaire il
y a un travail de fond minutieux utile
dans l'intérêt général du pays qui est
mené moi je crois qu'on peut aboutir
qu'on doit aboutir et qu'ensuite si
l'étape ce soir cette commission mixte
paritaire est passée il faudra voter ce
texte moi je le dis vous me mentionnez
je sais pas si c'est tellement vrai de
dire il aller de gauche il aller droite
en tout cas je crois pouvoir dire que je
suis là depuis le début et je dis à mes
amis politiques que d'abord ils devront
regarder le contenu de ce qui sort de
cette commission mixte paritaire ils
devront le faire comme chaque
parlementaire dans un esprit de
responsabilité parce qu'encore une fois
j'insiste sur un point personne ne
comprendrait les Français ne
comprendraient pas que nous ne puissions
pas aboutir et que à la fin de cette
semaine il n'y ait pas de texte voté sur
l'émigration donc vous dites à vos
parlementaires s'il y a acccord ce soir
il faut voter le texte il ne peut pas
manquer une voix à la majorité demain
lors V avec la plus grande clarté je le
dis parce que c'est insupportable
parfois quand on est parlementaire de se
voir mettre une forme de pression morale
je le dis sans se défaire de ce qui'est
son rôle de parlementaire c'est-à-dire
de regarder les choses au fond
c'est-à-dire de regarder point par point
sujet par sujet Quels sont les positions
parfois de compromis qui ont été trouvé
avec notamment la majorité sénatoriale
qu'elle avait fait le travail
contrairement à l'Assemblée nationale où
les oppositions Unies ont fait le choix
de ne pas avoir ce débat là mais je leur
dis de regarder les positions au fond
mais en responsabilité il nous fut un
texte sur l'immigration et vous pensez
qu'ils vous suivront est-ce que vous
pensez vraiment qu'il ne manquera aucune
voix je suis jamais là pour ni faire
Madame
Irma verou à moiti plein je suis là pour
essayer d'aider à remplir le verre d'une
certaine façon et donc faire en sorte
que à la fin on puisse collectivement
avancer mais moi j'ai j'ai déjà vécu je
pas 20 ans de de vie politique mais
beaucoup de fois ces situations où on
nous annonce que la majorité va exploser
qu'elle est profondément fracturée c'est
vrai qu'il peut y avoir des débats ils
sont sein et le sujet de l'immigration
n'est pas un sujet facile à appréhender
parce que c'est un sujet qui est
profondément humain parce que on doit
regarder des situations de personnes
qu'on connaît dans sa propre
circonscription ça n'est pas un sujet
facile mais à chaque fois qu'on nous a
annoncé l'explosion de la majorité moi
j'ai plutôt constaté que la majorité
elle a toujours été au rendez-vous y
compris dans les moments difficiles y
compris pr quand on a traversé quelques
tempêtes et depuis 6 ans il y en a eu et
donc je suis certain qu'à nouveau nous
serons rendez-vous rendez-vous de
l'intérêt général et de la
responsabilité parce que nos concitoyens
nous le demandent sur les les points à
tranché il y a notamment la question de
l'aide médicale d'État qui pourrait être
remise à plus tard Gérald armanin a
redit hier qu'il promettait un texte en
début d'année est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à cette solution est-ce que
c'est pas un peu mettre la poussière
sous le tapis non on a toujs s été clair
de dire que ce sujet là n'avait pas sa
place dans le texte immigration pour
toutes les raisons y compris législative
bon donc il y a pas de raison à ce que à
l'occasion de la CMP l'aide médicale
d'État reviennent dans ce texte là il y
a un travail qui a été mené un travail
très utile un travail transpartisan
c'est le travail de Monsieur stéphanini
et de Monsieur Évin qui viennent de
raisons politiques différents et qui ont
formulé un certain nombre de
propositions
que nous pourrons examiner de façon
pragmatique moi je pense que vous savez
c'est un sujet l'immigration sur lequel
il faut pas plaquer de la mauvaise
idéologie faut pas essayer d'avoir des
réflexes pavlovien sur cette question il
faut être très pragmatique partir du
réel et viser à chaque fois des
solutions qui vise l'efficacité
fa conduite moi je suis pas sur cette
position là je crois que l'aide médicale
d'État la démonstration a été faite que
c'est utile à la fois pour ceux qui en
bénéficie mais plus globalement pour
notre pays que ça répond à l'aspiration
première des soignants dans notre pays
c'est-à-dire de soigner ceux qui en ont
besoin c'est une position qui est très
claire qui n'est pas remise en cause
d'ailleurs par le rapport qui a été
rendu que j'évoqué à l'instant mais qui
n'est pas remise en cause par le Sénat
qui a restreint le sans supprer l' mé
mais une chose est sûre ce sujet-là ne
doit pas venir perturber le travail
encore une fois d'intérêt général qui
est mené autour du texte que nous avons
que les parlementaires auront à voter et
que nous nous avons apporté il y a un
autre sujet qui est fait débat c'est la
question des prestations sociales et du
délai pour accorder des certaines
prestations sociales celles qui sont non
contributives les républicains ont voté
un délai de 5 ans ici au Sénat est-ce
que vous accepteriez de lâcher là-dessus
oui moi je vais pas faire la CMP avant
la CMP je n'y participe pas et en tant
que ministre je n'ai pas de de mandat
c'est pas moi qui mène cette négociation
mais je crois que les choses ont été
très bien dites là encore à l'instant
par le sénateur qui m'a précédé là aussi
ça faisait partie des points qui
posaient problème objectivement pour
notre majorité sur lequel un travail est
nécessaire là aussi pour trouver une
position de compromis moi je crois que
la position telle qu'elle avait été
exprimée elle était difficilement
acceptable je pense que le ministre de
l'Intérieur l'a dit hier d'ailleurs il y
a un distingo qui doit être fait entre
ceux qui travaillent ceux qui ne
travaillent pas on doit pouvoir de façon
assez raisonnable exclure du champ de
cette discussion ceux qui ont inst stat
de réfugiés ceux qui ont un handicap
qu'ils subissent qu'il n'ont pas choisi
et donc on voit bien que grâce à
l'excellent travail qui est en train
d'être mené certes un peu en coulisse
parce que c'est ça une commission mixte
paritaire certes de façon accélérée
parce qu'il faut tout faire en 3 jours
là où peut-être quelques semaines de
débat aurait permis de mieux éclairer
les choses et bien je pense que là aussi
sur ce sujet nous sommes en position en
capacité de trouver le bon compromis
mais est-ce que ça vous coûterait c'est
ce qu'a dit hier yal brune pivé mais si
la position demeurait celle adoptée au
Sénat la réponse c'est oui mais depuis
un travail de fond a été mené là encore
pour que ça puisse ne pas être cette
position qui peut-être on verra bien
c'est à la fin du bal qu'on pay les
musiciens figurit en sortie de
commission mix paritaire Sacha aliier
c'était le premier à fustiger le texte
des républicains lui aussi tenant Donel
gauche président de la commission des
lois est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous lui
dites et ben il va falloir céder sur
certains points pour aller dans le sens
des lui dire ça Saou il va présider la
commission paritaire donc il fait partie
des parlementaires qui s engagé plus
qu'aucun autre sur ce texte de loi qui
travaille depuis la première minute avec
le ministre de l'Intérieur justement
pour bâtir là aussi des compromis et
donc il a c'est pas compliqué quand on a
autant critiqué le texte du Sénat de
battir un compromis aujourd'hui assister
à tous les débats présider au débat et
donc par nature quand on est président
de la commission des lois que il aura le
grand honneur de présider la commission
mix paritaire il est tout entier dans
justement ce travail de responsabilité
parlementaire donc moi j'ai pas de
leçons ou même de conseil à lui donner
il en est un des acteurs centraux et
donc je crois que il fera partie non
seulement de ceux qui
accepteront le compromis mais qui le
construiront et c'est plus importantc
est-ce que vous avez fait partie de ceux
au sein de la majorité qui pensent qu'il
ne faut pas trop céder au républicains
parce que il y a danger à mettre un
texte trop à droite j'essaie vous le
voyez d'exprimer les choses avec
beaucoup de clarté ce matin je vous dis
sans aucune ambigué les Français
attendent un texte sur l'immigration les
Français ne comprendraient pas que nous
ne votions pas un texte sur
l'immigration qui répond à des questions
d'intérêt général à des questions
vitales pour notre pays et donc nous
devons aboutir voilà quelle est ma
position et sincèrement je crois qu'elle
ne souffre d'aucune ambiguité vous dites
la même chose que gér drmanin qui disait
il y a quelques heures en gros s'il y a
pas de texte d' immigration on prend le
risque de Marine Le Pen àélysée en 2027
et c'est pas un peu risqué quand même
est-ce que vous ne lancez pas d'une
certaine manière vous-même la campagne
de Marine Le Pen je vous m'avez pas
entendu parler de Marine Le Pen mais
votre collègue minist ministre de
l'Intérieur je crois et je partage ce
point de vue ave Gérald d'Anin que les
extrêmes et singulièrement le
rassemblement national se nourrissent
des difficultés à chaque fois qu'il y a
des difficultés c'est leur fond de
commerce et on voit bien d'ailleurs
qui ne souhait en aucun cas régler les
difficultés parce que on efface leur
fond de commerce et donc ne pas aboutir
sur un texte qui apporte des solutions
j'insiste sur ce pointl parce qu'on
finit quasiment parfois par s'éloigner
du fond des débats mais ce que vous nous
dit NZ pas cité marine Le Pen vous
n'riez pas cité marine Le Pen ce que je
donne pas les bons points et les mauvais
points je dis que nous devons de façon
obsessionnelle apporter des solutions au
problèmes qui se posent dans la vie des
Français et si nous le faisons alors
nous ferons reculer le rassemblement
national moi je suis convaincu que si
Emmanuel Macron a battu pour une
deuxième fois Marine Le Pen lors de
l'élection présidentielle c'est parce
que dans le premier quinquena nous
n'avons pas tout bien fait c'est évident
mais nous avons apporté des solutions
notamment sur les sujets économiques
nous avons enclenché la bataille du
plein emploi nous avons fait reculer le
chômage de mche et que ceci à la fin
c'est reconnu par nos concitoyens la
situation du pays elle est suffisamment
tendue elle est suffisamment
conflictuelle pour que on ne remette pas
de l'huile sur le feu systématiquement
mais que on garde cette stratégie des
solutions j'entends cette petite musique
qui consisterait à dire au fond faut
tourner le dos à la politique des
solution c'est pas ça qui fonctionne
contre le rassemblé nationale moi je
crois que c'est ça qui fonctionne et il
faut à chaque fois aller montrer la
vérité des prix d'une certaine façon
voyez sur suet de l'immigration c'est
intéressant de constater qu'on a à la
fois un débat nation et puis un débat à
l'échelle européenne que aujourd'hui
même est mis en discussion un texte sur
justement le pacte sur l'asile et sur
l'immigration en Europe qui ne veut pas
faire aboutir ce Pact là les amis de
Marine Le Pen Jordane Bardella et son
groupe parlementaire au Parlement
européen pourquoi parce que cela
apporterait des solutions et on voit
qu'ils sont d'ailleurs à rebours des
états même je pense à Madame mélonie par
exemple qui sont de la même famille
politique mais une fois en
responsabilité voir à quel point on a
besoin de porter des solutions donc
voyez il faut qu'on mette le doigt sur
l'imposture que représente le
rassemblement national et à chaque fois
qu'on le fait et bien on se donne une
chance de les faire reculer mais il faut
pas partir battu dans ces débats là il
faut mener ce combat politique justement
sur l'Europe et sur la question
européenne les républicains ont remis
sur la table leur idée de réforme
constitutionnelle ils ont écrit une
lettre à Emmanuel Macron avec notamment
la leur volonté de faire primer le droit
national sur le droit européen hier il y
avait un sondage dans le Journal du
Dimanche qui disait qu'une majorité des
Français étaient fav à cette primuté du
droit national sur le droit européen en
matière d'immigration y compris chez les
sympathisants Renaissance est-ce qu'il
faut mettre ce débat sur la table moi je
je crois aucun débat n'est tabou voilà
je je le dire de façon très très très
claire et à chaque fois qu'on donne
l'impression d'une certaine façon de
détourner le regard je pas sûr que on en
sorte gagnant donc ayons les débats mais
ma conviction la plus profonde c'est que
en matière d'immigration ce qu'attendent
nos concitoyens c'est de l'efficacité
voilà c'est pas de l'idéologie c'est de
l'efficacité et du pragmatisme en
l'occurrence le débat
consti il nous porterait bien loin des
semaines ou des mois qui sont devant
nous il y a des élections européennes
c'est un bon débat pour ces élections
européennes encore une fois dans ces
élections parlons du fond nous avons là
l'occasion assez historique pour
l'Europe de se doter de nouveaux outils
d'adopter impact sur l'asile et
l'immigration qui remet à plat les
règles du jeu en Europe vous m'avez déjà
entendu sur votre plateau à quel point
le système européen disfonctionne
aujourd'hui sur les questions
d'immigration à quel point le système
dit de Dublin disfonctionne aujourd'hui
et créer un système où au fond les
individus sont baladés d'un pays à un
autre avec des règles qui sont
complètement dysfonctionnelles nous
remettons ces questionsl au cœur et sur
la table ayons ce débat les élections
européennes c'est un bon moment pour
parler de fond pour parler des grands
sujets qui structure la vie des états et
la vie de notre Union européenne et je
peux vous garantir une chose c'est que
quand rentre dans le débat sur le fond
alors il y a plus grand monde du côté du
rassemblement national allons leur
demander quelles sont leurs solutions
mettons en évidence queles sont leurs
contradictions ça c'est le combat que
nous devons mener absolument et sans
aucune ambigué est-ce qu'en cas d'échec
soit ce soir en CMP soit demain l'heure
du vote la question de l'avenir du
quinquena sera posée pour vous je pense
que vu l'importance du sujet l'attendu
de la part de nos concitoyens d'aboutir
c'est une question qui est structurante
dans notre quin Kena c'est une question
qui est structurante tout simplement
pour la vie du pays et c'est ça qui doit
compter ne faisons pas ce que les
politiques ont fait pendant trop
longtemps c'est-à-dire de faire en sorte
que les Français soi pas le cœur de la
vie politique mais soit le décor de la
vie politique ce texte il est important
non pas pour la majorité non pas pour le
gouvernement il est important pour la
vie des gens il est important parce que
les gens veulent qu'on trouve des
solutions est-ce que ce sera la fin du
qu ça que je suis pas venu faire des
phrases grandillquant c'est d'une
certaine façon
un point secondaire que
l'organisation de la majorité ou des
conséquences politiques et
cetera le point premier c'est ce sont
les enjeux sur le fond encore une fois
et ils sont je crois pas détournés le
regard ce matin très
important c'est un moment politique très
important moi je crois pas tellement à
cette question de la la dissolution je
crois encore une fois que il y a un an
et demi maintenant les Français ont fait
à nouveau confiance auès président de la
République Emmanuel Macron qu'il a un
cap pour notre pays et que ce qui est
l'attendu c'est que nous puissions
mettre en œuvre pour le plein emploi
pour l'immigration pour le retour des
services publics sur nos territoires les
solutions que nos concitoyens attendent
on va parler de vos dossiers oui
absolument vous parlez de service public
moi je voudrais vous parler des service
public dans nos territoires avec cette
problématique des secrétaires de mairie
l'attractivité est devenue de plus en
plus difficile pour les Mairies est-ce
que vous êtes favorable à l'augmentation
des salaires des traitements des
secrétaires mairie si oui avec quel
argent oui et je crois en avoir fait la
démonstration moi vous savez j'ai j'ai
fait cette question les secrétaires de
mairie je vous remercie de m'en parler
parce que on en parle pas vous vous en
parlez beaucoup tous les jours sur les
plateaux de télévision et pourtant ce
métier-là de secrétairees de mairie
c'est un métier qui est essentiel dans
les 29000 communes dans lequelles il y a
des secrétaires de mairie le boulot ne
pourrait pas se faire sans leur
secrétaire de de mairie et c'est un des
métiers qui est les plus en enstion
peut-être le plus entention de toute la
fonction publiqueut territoriale et donc
moi je me suis engagé et c'est le
travail que nous avons mené dans la loi
avec les parlementaires C exactement
voilà une CMP qui a abouti pour un sujet
qui est essentiel qui est certes
peut-être qui concerne moins de gens
mais quoi que parce que ce sont derrière
les services publics du quotidien pour
tous ceux qui habitent dans des communes
de petite taille dans des zones rurales
notamment et donc cet engagement c'est
engagement de revalorisation du métier
des secrétaires de mi de reconnaissance
que leur métier c'est pas un métier de
catégorie C pardon pour cette aspect qui
parlera peut-être pas à tout le monde
mais en tout cas qui est un métier à
forte responsabilité à forte engagement
qui doit trouver une reconnaissance
professionnel dans la fonction publique
je me suis engagé pour qu'on puisse
promouvoir les secrétaires de mairie par
la formation par la reconnaissance des
acquis de l'expérience qu'on puisse
mieux les rémunérer et faire en sorte
qu'ell franchissent des eselot P qui pay
dans vous la situation est tendue quand
même dans les communes les taxes
d'habitation foncière pardon ont explosé
qui paye dansz d'abord vous répondre
sans ambiguité sur le fait que oui il
faut revaloriser leur métier et c'est
l'engagement je crois que nous avons
tous pris et si le Sénat et l'Assemblée
ce soir le conclu nous allons transcrire
dans la loi ensuite il y a des
employeurs territoriaux que sont les
mairie qui d'ailleurs ne discuteent pas
la nécessité de revaloriser les
secrétaires de mairie il faut
accompagner les employeurs publics non
pas en découpant les sujets une fois sur
les secrétaires de mairie une autre fois
pourevaloriser les adsem c'est un autre
engagement que nous devons prendre mais
nous devons avoir ce débat budgétaire
systématiquement les mairies elles ont
un certain nombre de coûts par
l'inflation par les revalorisations
salariales que j'assume parfaitement des
recettes notre majorité est venu mettre
non seulement fin à la baisse des
dotations générales de fonctionnement
mais nous avons redonné des moyens et
donc c'est à travers ces moyensl que
nous devons donner les moyens aux
employeurs de mieux rémunérer leurs
agents mais vous savez au-delà de cette
question Je prépare un projet de loi
pour la f pardon je vous fais vos
transition mais mais d'un mot et je vous
laisse promis m'interroger là-dessus il
faut redonner des marges de manœuvre aux
employeurs moi ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'on puisse avoir un choc de confiance
et de responsabilité ce qui est très
difficile à expliquer aujourd'hui à des
employeurs territoriaux mais aussi des
directrices ou des directeurs d'hôpitaux
ou même des managers dans les
administrations déconcentrées c'est
qu'ils aient aucune marge de manœuvre
c'est que tout doit soit décidé d'en
haut depuis Paris moi je crois qu'il
faut faire confiance aux agents de la
fonction publique mais il faut faire
confiance aussi aux employeurs qui
prennent leur décisions sur les
promotions sur les recrutements sur les
rémunérations je veux redonner des
marges de manœuvre à ceux qui sont près
du terrain sur votre projet de loi
fonction publique il sera toujours
présenté en janvier en conseil des
ministres on a toujours évoqué le
premier trimestre la première ministre a
évoqué le mois de février la fin du mois
de février pour présenter ce texte
important pour l'efficacité de notre
fonction publique c'est-à-dire de nos
services public et donc nous tiendrons
ce calendrier donc fin février en
conseil des ministres oui c'est le le le
le calendrier que nous avons construit
avec la première ministre et au
Parlement avant l'été et au Parlement
avant l'été je souhaite pouvoir
présenter ce texte à la représentation
nationale le mettre au débat dans le
premier semestre de l'année donc
c'est-à-dire avant l'été euh c'est un
texte qui vise à remettre totalement à
plat le statut de fonctionnaire et de
quelle manière c'est un texte je le
disais qui vise à redonner des marges de
manœuvre et à faire confiance à ceux qui
sont près du terrain moi je veux
redonner beaucoup plus de mobilité dans
la fonction publique je souhaite qu'on
puisse rentrer plus facilement dans la
fonction publique je souhaite qu'on
puisse évoluer plus facilement dans la
fonction publique je souhaite parfois
qu'on puisse aussi sortir plus
facilement de la fonction publique je
souhaite qu'on puisse valoriser le
travail davantage encore récompenser
ceux qui s'engagent individuellement
collectivement que c question de la
rémunération au mérite fasse partie des
débats qu'on doit avoir c'est pas un
gros mot dans le la bouche du ministre
de la Fonction publique que de parler de
mérite que de parler de valeur de talent
c'était d'ailleurs les termes qui était
dans le statut de la fonction publique
vous m'interrogez sur le statut quand on
relit le statut tel qu'il a été pensé
par Maurice 19 uniquement d'automaticité
d'augmentation avec des échelles et des
points mais aussi une valorisation vous
savez ce qui est structurant dans le
statut et moi je ne souhaite pas
remettre en cause le statut de la
fonction public je crois qu' a sa sa
singularité au fond et que travailler
dans la fonction publique être agent
public c'est pas travailler pour une
entreprise c'est un C de droit et de
devoirs c'est l'égalité d'accès aux
emplois c'est la neutralité du service
public c'est l'adaptabilité aussi des
des services publics tout ça il faut le
conserver mais ça veut pas dire que le
statut c'est le statut qu mais ça veut
dire rémunérer au mérite de ceux qui
travaillent est-ce que ça veut dire a
des lignes la notion de de mérite pardon
mais elle était strictement inscrite
dans le statut tel qu'il a été pensé
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale par
ceux qui l'ont construit et donc c'est
pas le truc le plus misise en œuvre
reconnaissez mais je je le regrette
aujourd'hui parce que que ça veut dire
aussi sanctionner ceux qui trava pas
c'est que sur le terrain mais les agents
publics sont formidablement engagés vous
me parlez des secrétaires de mairie vous
me parlez des agents qui dans nos
communes dans nos administrations se
décarcasse pour qu'on puisse rendre des
services publics et qui vivent toutes
les crises de la société qui sont
d'ailleurs en première ligne souvent
exposé aussi aux dérives et au risques
de notre société et donc oui moi je
souhaite qu'on puisse davantage
récompenser cet engagement rémunérer une
équipe qui par exemple se fixerait des
objectifs en terme de qualité
d'efficacité de service public qui
s'engage dans des projets de transition
écologique c'està-dire dans tout ce qui
constitue les grands défis de notre
société mais aujourd'hui le constat que
je fais c'est que les employeurs publics
les managers dans la fonction publique
là non plus ça n'est pas un gros mot
c'est pas parce qu'on est dans le
service public un manager subitement ça
devrait être un petit chef on puisse
leur donner les outils et les marches de
manœuvre pour justement mieux rémunérer
leurs agents à partir d'objectif de
terrain c'est là aussi un attendu très
fort de la part de nos concitoyens que
de redonner plus d'efficacité à nos
services publics merci s on suivra la
présentation de ce texte en février donc
viendreit nous en reparler avec plaisir
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
merci Fabrice merci bonne semaine SEM mè
à vous pass au club des
territoires